[Music]
on this thursday night a boost to the
vaccine rollout
millions of canadians will get their
second dose sooner than expected
while confusion lingers about the
astrazeneca shot
to use it or lose it and more provinces
prepare to reopen
busted the federal ndp leader caught on
camera violating pandemic protocols
getting cash to go green at the new
federal grant to help make your home
more energy efficient and justice
decades later 33 months of his life
wiped off the slate the apology to
italian canadians
interned during the second world
[Music]
global war with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with some news about the
interval between doses of covid19
vaccine
up to 50 million doses are expected by
the end of july in canada and more
provinces say
enough is on route now to reduce the
weight for that crucial second dose
in british columbia the wait for a
second shot is now about
eight weeks for pfizer and moderna
instead of 16 weeks
now that we have a steady supply coming
to bc
the number of people who now have their
first dose is high enough
that we're able to speed up delivery of
second doses for the age-based and cev
immunizations
how long you'll have to wait for your
second shot does depend on where you
live
each province is setting its own
timelines and there are different
second dose strategies for the mrna
vaccines and the astrazeneca vaccine
getting both doses faster will be a game
changer both in how we interact with
each other
and where we can travel in tonight's top
story abigail beeman brings us
up to speed on the changing timelines
with an uptick in vaccine supply more
than half of the country's provinces
have announced some kind of move to
reduce
dose intervals our delivery plan for
second doses has been sped up by about
two to four weeks
everybody having being vaccinated prior
to august 31st
we are planning for all eligible
manitobans to receive
their second dose should they want one
by end
of july during a vaccine drought the
national advisory committee on
immunization stretched out the gap to 16
weeks to protect as many people as
possible with a first
dose the initial strategy i think was
ideal for the situation we were in
it's it's time to change dr fahad razak
has seen a dramatic decrease
in patients in the toronto covet ward
he's been running the patients who i
admitted with covert they fall really
into two groups the first is people
who haven't received that first dose but
the second
are people who have received it but
probably didn't mount enough of an
immune response and would have benefited
from a second dose
he and many others are pushing to get
second doses into more at-risk canadians
faster and while there is recent data
out of the uk suggesting the antibody
response is greater in older people who
waited 12 weeks between
pfizer doses we actually don't know if
that makes any difference
practically speaking in terms of the
immune protection that you have
there's also the separate issue of
astrazeneca with questions around
whether canadians will be able to
choose an mrna vaccine for their booster
thursday quebec announced people can get
a second astrazeneca shot after just
eight weeks i'm very worried that we're
basically going to end up throwing
vaccine away while in ontario confusion
prevails it took family dr michelle
cohen two weeks of phone calls and upset
tweets before public health picked up
her leftover 230 doses
expiring may 31st we don't know what's
going on we keep asking we're offering
to drive it places we've got no
information
so i was pretty angry global news asked
federal public health officials if they
expect provinces to eventually get down
to the manufacturer recommended interval
that's three or four weeks for pfizer
and moderna
dr howard new said he didn't think
provinces would drop below an
8 or 10 week gap but he pinned his
answer to science
rather than supply saying that could
change based on new data
abigail beeman global news ottawa
there is some new clarity tonight on
when canada will get its next shipment
of moderna the federal government says
it's expecting
500 000 doses next week and 1.5 million
doses
mid-june oderna was expected to send
more than 14 million doses by the end of
june so far only about
5.6 million have actually been delivered
more than 22 million vaccine doses have
been given out so far in canada
53 percent of people have now had at
least one dose
4.6 percent have been fully vaccinated
western university in ontario is
mandating that students living in
residence must be vaccinated before they
can return
to in-person classes this fall students
at western's affiliated university
colleges will also be required to have
at least one dose
assuming there's enough vaccine supply
those who can't get the shot before
arriving
will have 14 days after they move in to
get vaccinated
there are some exceptions including
those who can't get the shot for medical
reasons
an on-campus vaccination clinic will be
set up this summer at western for
students
staff and faculty manitoba still has the
highest rate of active infections per
capita in north america
and it is extending its covet 19
restrictions
we're not in a position to reopen and we
are not in a position to
uh send our students who are currently
in remote learning situations back into
the classroom either
hundreds of schools across manitoba will
remain closed until at least june 7th
and a ban on gatherings and businesses
will be extended
for another two weeks prince edward
island has
the lowest rate of infection in the
country and no one there has died from
covet 19
those accomplishments were acknowledged
today as the province announced its
reopening plan
the five staff plan culminates in
september after 80 percent of residents
over the age of 12 are expected
to be fully vaccinated there will be
limited public health measures at that
point
in august the province will allow
visitors from outside atlantic canada
with no self-isolation requirements for
fully vaccinated travelers
and new brunswick's health ministers
says that province could drop all
restrictions as early as august 2nd but
only if at least 75 percent of people
are fully vaccinated
the first of the province's three-step
plan could begin as early as june 7th
with the gradual lifting of restrictions
provided vaccinations stay on track and
there is not a sharp rise in
hospitalizations
it means no self-isolation or testing
for travelers within atlantic canada
except for nova scotia that province
would rejoin the atlantic bubble
july 1st while the calgary stampede is
hoping to attract visitors from across
the country this july
it will be the first major event in
canada since the pandemic began
but can organizers pull it off without
putting the public
at risk heather urex west reports
on the grounds of stampede park
preparations are well
underway the nashville north tent is
under construction
getting set to host live music something
that now
seems so foreign after so many months of
covid 19 restrictions
the stampede will be the first major
event in canada to move forward
since the beginning of the covid crisis
and that's a responsibility that we do
not take in any way lightly
the stampede says there will be covet
safety protocols in place
masks may be required there won't be any
dancing in the nashville north tent
and some events like the chuckwagon
races won't happen
at all the midway food fun animals all
of those experiences
will be here they're just they'll look a
little different
i'm somewhat anxious about it myself
it's an immensely
complicated situation because you'd be
thinking about who goes to stampede how
likely are they to been immunized
how can the risk be managed when you're
trying to bring together such a large
group of people
people that will be coming from other
communities too next door in bc there
are still
travel restrictions in place those from
alberta and
elsewhere are still asked to stay away
dr brian conway says those restrictions
could be
safely eased as covid cases fall and
more people receive their first
and even second vaccine dose if we do
all of that
right numbers will go down there'll be
no new hot spots
and i would feel comfortable about
allowing inter-provincial travel
but it's a cautious comfort he says that
depends on things like new variants
staying away and the vaccine rollout
staying strong
summer may be a few weeks away but as
we've seen so often in this pandemic
in just a few weeks a lot can change
heather eurex west global news calgary
the toronto startup company switch
health has managed hundreds of thousands
of coveted tests for international
travelers
arriving in canada company
representatives will appear before the
house of commons health committee
tomorrow
to answer questions about managing their
government contract for border testing
and insiders who have spoken to global
news say there are concerns the company
must address roberta bell reports
while you are waiting to talk to a nurse
global news spoke to five workers about
their experiences
supervising covid test swabbing for
switch health
and is protecting their identities for
fear of workplace reprisal
all five say they were hired for the job
by subcontractor blast marketing
that's what they click on before i i
connect via
video so it means to be told
twice that employee claims they've had
to tell patients they're being misled
the federal government awarded a nearly
100 million dollar contract to toronto
startup company switch health
to manage this system switch health has
repeatedly declined interviews with
global news
but maintains most of the telehealth
team supervising the testing
is comprised of nurses at most only 2.9
percent is not
insert the swab and while experts say
this type of anterior nasal testing
doesn't necessarily require the
supervision of a medical professional
ontario says only qualified nurses may
use the title of nurse
violators could be fined up to fifty
thousand dollars under the province's
nursing act
after global news began investigating on
may 12th
blast marketing directed some employees
in a group chat
to immediately start referring to
themselves as telehealth generalists
and not telehealth nurse assistants
switch health says it has since updated
its language and informed all employees
in a written statement it says
generalists work alongside its nursing
team and have oversight by a registered
nurse or registered practical nurse
and that its leadership has never
instructed an individual who is not
licensed or registered as a nurse
to identify themselves as a nurse and is
not aware of any record of this
occurring
behind the scenes it's pure madness
global news has also agreed to protect
the identity of this former blast
marketing employee
she says she spent two months offering
customer support to travelers
switch health says employees receive
proper training and that it has
designated teams to provide it
but this employee says they just got a
day we just write in
into a group chat full of equally lost
people
and it's all of us asking the same
questions like this is my client what do
we do here blast marketing says it has
no knowledge or indication that any of
its team members are fraudulently
presenting themselves that way
the public health agency of canada says
it's now aware of such concerns and is
actively following up
roberta bell global news regina
well we've all been longing to hug
friends and loved ones again ndp leader
jagmeet singh has gone ahead
and done it these pictures have emerged
of sing not wearing a mask and hugging
someone who is not part of his household
we are all tired of the restrictions and
political leaders who have spent the
last year telling us to obey them
aren't exempt from following them
michael couture reports
i encourage everyone to continue to
follow all the public health guidelines
that was jug meet singh on wednesday
reinforcing public health advice to
canadians as we continue to battle this
third wave
of covet 19. however video obtained by
global news
shows he didn't follow that same advice
back on may the 8th
in it singh is seen getting out of a car
with a provincial ndp staffer
neither of them is wearing a mask on
their face and they hug
yeah i slide the mask around my neck and
it's one of those things i just
forgot that i was not yet actually
safe to take it down singh and the
staffer had just returned from a
drive-through iftar event where both men
were seen
wearing masks and following public
health guidelines
singh even posed for pictures with
people at the event
while keeping a safe distance still he
admits
it was a lapse in judgment that
shouldn't have happened this
happens a lot of people at the end of
the day you kind of let down your guard
and i'm sorry for that and i really want
i really hope that
that this this doesn't discourage anyone
from wearing their masks and following
public health protocols like many
politicians who are used to handshakes
and hugs
singh says until that day he'd been very
careful navigating meet and greets
and admits he made a mistake and so i
reverted back to
the pre-pandemic days where i would i
would greet my friends
with a hug or say bye with a hug
something we all hope we can get back to
doing
once health rules allow mike licouter
global news
ottawa
help to upgrade your house coming up
ottawa's new grant
to make homes greener
you could be eligible for a new federal
program to help make your home
more energy efficient the greener homes
grant will help
pay up to five thousand dollars for
things like solar panels and replacing
old furnaces
our chief political correspondent david
aiken explains the theory behind it
and how to apply well donna back in 2007
the harper government had a very similar
home energy retrofit program and it was
wildly popular more than
half a million canadians took federal
cash for
home renovations before that program was
shut down in 2012.
but now the trudeau government is
resurrecting that program
turning what the harper government
called the eco energy retrofit program
into the canada greener homes grant
program
a cash handout of up to five thousand
dollars to homeowners
for qualifying projects as a homeowner
you don't want to have to pay extra
money on energy bills because of a leaky
window
when you could save that money for
school supplies or groceries
and as a country every effort counts to
keep our air clean and our environment
healthy eligible projects could include
replacing oil furnaces or low efficiency
systems
improving or replacing insulation
installing
high efficiency water heaters or solar
panels
fixing drafty windows or doors this is
a good program to fight climate change
save homeowners money
and uh and create jobs but there are
many other things we're doing as well
minutes after trudeau's announcement an
online portal opened up
where homeowners can apply to get into
the program i was going to make our
business go through the roof there's no
doubt about it in fact
as i was just mentioning to you my
phone's been ringing off the hook for
the last two hours
people hearing about the news the grants
are also retroactive
for work done as far back as december
1st 2020
but there's no hurry the program is set
to run
for the next five years and it might be
a while before canadians can take full
advantage of this program
for one thing with the home building
boom in many cities around the country
it can be tough to find a contractor in
second with the price of lumber and
other building materials near an
all-time
high well doing a home rental right now
might be kind of pricey even with
the federal cash donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thanks
still ahead china fights back on
theories about the origins of covid19
china is accusing the biden
administration of politicizing the
investigation into the origins of the
novel coronavirus
president biden has ordered a review of
the intelligence about
where the virus emerged a chinese
foreign ministry spokesperson says this
shows that
they don't care about the facts or the
truth and have zero interest in a
serious science-based study of origins
their one aim is to use the pandemic to
pursue stigmatization and political
manipulation to shift the blame
the theory that the virus may have
accidentally leaked from a lab in wuhan
in late 2019
is gaining traction china has repeatedly
denied any link
prime minister justin trudeau says he
supports the call by the u.s and other
countries to better understand the
origins of covet 19 to
ensure accountability and better protect
the world
from future pandemics
next an apology decades after the
internment of italian canadians
what we owe each other is the truth that
was the message from french president
emmanuel macron
rwanda today he asked for forgiveness
and admitted france bears terrible
responsibility for the 1994 rwandan
genocide
mackerel said well france was not an
accomplice in the genocide
terrible errors in judgment were made
and warnings ignored
he said france had for too long valued
silence over examination of the truth
ethnic hutus killed more than 800 000
people most of them
members of the tutsi minority in carnage
that lasted
about 100 days france and other western
powers
failed to intervene to the men
and women who were taken to prisoner of
war camps
or jail without charge
people who are no longer with us to hear
this apology
to the tens of thousands of innocent
italian canadians who were labeled
enemy aliens we
prime minister trudeau formally
apologized today to italian canadians
who were sent to internment camps during
the second world war
it was feared they were supporters of
the fascist italian dictator benito
mussolini who had allied himself with
adolf hitler
though as mike armstrong explains some
of those in turned had sons fighting
in the canadian military there is
very little left today but this site in
kananaskis alberta was once
internment camp 130. it's one of the
places where during the second world war
italian canadians were locked up none of
those men are still alive today but
their experiences are still felt
by the generations that followed
salvatore vestarki was picked up in june
of 1940
in montreal 33 months of his life wiped
off the slate
your father could have been bitter
no oh yeah he was could have been no he
wasn't
he wasn't he just wondered why
when italy allied itself with nazi
germany in 1940
canada declared about 31 000 italian
canadians
as enemy aliens about 600 men and four
women were interned
without a trial salvatore vistaki spent
most of his time
in this camp in petawawa ontario after
being picked up
on the day he asked his girlfriend to
marry him
that that's a real hurt to go home
after a nice dinner after finally
finding the girl or finding the man that
you want you go to bed you're happy and
there's a knock on your door
and the next thing you're in handcuffs
not too nice now for some there was
insult added to injury there were men
who were interned by canada
while their sons fought for canada in
europe there was even a man whose son
had to leave school to support the
family
and was then conscripted into the
canadian army
my father built both sides of the street
starchy's father
rebuilt his life and went into business
as a homebuilder
he basically built the whole
neighborhood his daughter says he would
always tell her
someday there would be justice
she says this was that day
it's a happy day how unfortunate
is it that this apology comes when your
father's not here to hear us yeah
yeah that's what i really regret at
least if
one of them had been alive that would
have been
amazing but you know what
they know they know
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
we leave you tonight with news about a
book that was in heavy rotation in my
house and the homes of millions of
people
the man who created the very hungry
caterpillar has died
eric carl was an author and illustrator
who created many other beloved classics
he was 91 years old his team posted on
twitter thank you for sharing your
talent with generations
of young readers take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye